the riddler always pushes batman to his
mental limits and it's no different in
the batman batman's foe leaves cards for
him to find but there is more to them
that initially meets the eye keep
watching to learn why the riddler's
cards mean more than you think the
riddler has never been more of an
enigmatic figure than in the batman
while previous live-action iterations
have seen the character as a bit of a
jokester particularly when it comes to
jim carrey's take on the character in
batman forever he's deadly serious in
this one taking on the aesthetic of a
zodiac type serial killer in gotham to
make that real world connection all the
more apparent riddler leaves behind
puzzles and ciphers at the scenes of his
crimes for batman and gotham pd to solve
he's cryptic all the way down to his
capture that's the point where the cops
realize he has two separate id cards on
him however riddler may be even slyer
than most viewers initially give him
credit for as it turns out he hid secret
batman references throughout many of the
film's scenes in plain sight but you
have to be a real batman aficionado to
catch all of them it becomes a recurring
motif throughout the batman that riddler
leaves a card behind for the titular
vigilante at each crime scene the cards
hold significance to the plot by
typically containing a riddle for batman
to solve
having a clue
let's play a game just me and you but
the cards themselves make for fun easter
eggs all on their own for eagle-eyed
fans each card connects to a different
batman villain perhaps the best-known
example of this is with the first card
containing an owl featured in the batman
trailer many fans quickly pointed out
the connection to the court of owl's
storyline with many believing the ark
could factor into the sequel's plot it's
unknown if that will be the case but it
nonetheless makes for a fun addition
similar easter eggs can be found with
the remaining four cards as each one
connects with a different batman villain
the second card contains an image of a
mad scientist who bears a striking
resemblance to hugo strange the third
card features a picture of a woman
dressed in green which immediately makes
one think of poison ivy the fourth card
is where things get tricky it's just a
black background with two large eyes
looking toward the viewer it's
reminiscent of the cheshire cat in alice
in wonderland and of course batman has a
villain who goes by the name of mad
hatter last but not least the fifth and
final card has a boy with a puppet fans
of batman the animated series will
likely recall the ventriloquist and
scarface a man and puppet duo who commit
various crimes in gotham any of these
villains would make fun additions to the
batman mythos but for now they're
relegated to references batman has some
of the most iconic adversaries out of
any villain out there no doubt this has
helped in part from the litany of batman
projects that have materialized over the
years giving fans a glimpse into the
likes of scarecrow penguin and more
while the cards hinting at other
villains within batman lore would be
enough for most filmmakers there are
additional stronger hints that some of
batman's foes are out there just waiting
to make a grand entrance in the batman 2
and beyond the most obvious reference to
this is when riddler is locked away
toward the end of the film he's
naturally bummed that his plans went
into the sewer and he could use some
cheering up that's where his cellmate
next door comes in handy while this
individual never receives a name anyone
who's seen a batman property before can
surmise its joker by the signature laugh
in reference to clowns
you can call me
joker
that's not the only potential reference
found in the film as batman fights
riddler's minions he finds himself
between a rock and a hard place he's
beaten and worn down but it's catwoman
who is at the mercy of one of their foes
to give himself a quick burst of energy
batman reaches for a vial containing a
green liquid he then injects himself
with the material and suddenly he's on
his feet once again and beating the bad
guys given the enhanced strength and
brutality he displayed it seems the
substance is awfully similar to the
venom bane has used throughout his run
as one of batman's villains could this
mean we'll get joker and bane in one
movie in the future one can only hope
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]